première image prise par le Nautile se
sous-marin français le seul capable de
descendre jusqu'à 4000 mètres de
profondeur et plus c'est là que j depuis
1912 la carcasse du Titanic en plein
océan Atlantique une casserole en cuivre
de la vaisselle un coffre-fort et
différents objets d'art ont été remontés
au cours des 21 plongées une voiture
Renault de l'époque a même été repéré à
l'avant du navire des opérations
extrêmement délicates et dangereuses
auxquelles participaient une jeune femme
qui a plongé avec les équipes du
nautiques
mais je dois dire que plonge à 4000
mètres solo pour aller voir le Titanic
est tombé nez à nez avec une bouteille
de Coca-Cola c'est curieux